Now what makes stochastic games more interesting, perhaps, than repeated
games, is the idea that the actions that the players take
impact not just the rewards, but also future states. Right? And,
so this is the same issue that comes up when we're
talking about mark off decision processes and the way we
dealt with it in that setting was by defining a value
function. So, it seems pretty reasonable to try to go after
that same idea again. So what I've got here is actually
the Belmont Equation And let's look at this together and let's
see if we can fix it because it's not quite right.
>> Okay.
>> For dealing with the idea of zero sum in a stochastic
game. Okay so you remember the Belmen equation? We've got Q I star.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> So there was no I before, but Q star is the state. Is
to find over state actions, so here
we're going to define it over action, joint actions
>> Mm-hm.
>> For the two players, action pairs. The immediate reward to player
i for take, for that joint action in that
state plus the discounted expected value of the next state.
So we need to factor in the transition probabilities So
the transition of actually going to some next state s
prime is s, sorry t of s, AB as
prime. Right? So now, we're imagining what happens when we
land in S prime. So what I've written here says,
well, we're going to basically look a the Q values
in the state that we landed in, and kind
of summarize them, summarize that value back up so
that we can use it to define the, the
value of the state that we left. You with me?
>> I am with you.
>> Alright so if we put this in if, if we say the
way we're going to summarize the value for the new state that we land
in. Is we think of it as actually a matrix game. That there's
payoffs for each action choices of A prime and B prime. And over all
of those, we need to kind of summarize well which of those actions in this table
of values that we get for s prime.
Which of those values are we going to propagate forward
and call the value of that state? So what we did in regular MDPs is that we
said we'll take a max over all the
actions or in this case all the joint actions.
>> Uhun. So what do you think that translates to?
>> Well you wrote down max but that doesn't make sense,
that doesn't, that can't be right.
>> Well it translates, it means something. It
just doesn't mean what we mean it to mean.
>> That's true, that's fair.
>> So what does it mean and then, and then, how can
we fix it? So let's start off with what does it mean.
>> It means that you kind of always assume
that the joint actions that are going to be taken
Will benefit you the most. So, everyone, everyone is
trying to make you happy so, this makes you optimistic?
>> yeah, sort of optimistic
to the point of, of
>> Delusion?
>> Yes, very good. Right, it just basically says that whenever we're in a
state, the whole world is going to choose
their actions to benefit me, and this is
not what we get a say a zero sum stacastic game, but a zero
sum stacastic game, we should be you know. Like fighting it out at this point.
>> So that would work out if everybody's rewards were the same,
or everybody's rewards were the sum
of everyone's rewards, or something like that.
>> That's right.
If it was some kind of team based game.
>> Mm.
>> Or if everybody was, you know, going to sacrifice their
own happiness for the benefit of Qi, or i I mean.
>> Hm. So it's not reasonable to assume that. In
fact, what was it that we were assuming when we
had a zero sum game that was just a single
stage? Right? Just a single game and then we were done.
>> Oh, that people were doing minimax.
>> Right.
>> And maximin.
>> So what if we changed the equation to look like that?
So, what I mean by this, is when, when we
we evaluate the value of a state. We actually solve the
zero sum game in the Q values and take that value
and use it in the, in the context of this equation.
>> That seems closer to right.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's not an unreasonable
thing to do. It's just to say, I'm going to
summarize the future by imagining that we're going to play
that game that represents, you know, all the future.
>> Sure.
>> And I'm going to act in such a way to,
to try to Maximize that assuming you're trying to minimize
it, which makes perfect sense if it's a zero-sum game.
>> Right. I was, yeah, and we're still, we're
still acting as if there are only two people here.
>> Yeah, yeah, that's right. It turns out
that when you're talking about zero-sum it really
implies that there's only two players. Because if
you have a zero-sum three player game, it
really is just a general sum game. You can imagine that the third player is just
an extra factor that's just messing with the
numbers to make things sum up to zero.
So, yeah, so zero sum really does kind of focus on this two player setting.
>> That makes sense.
>> So we got this modified kelvin equation
and we can even translate it into a form
that's like Q learning. So the analog of
the kelvin equation and the Q learning update in
this setting would be that we. If we're
in some state, there's some joint action that's taken,
there's some pair of rewards that comes and
some next state that's visited that the Q value
for that state, joint action pair, is going to be updated to be closer
to, the reward for player i plus the discounted expected value, or sorry, the
discounted Summarized value or v value of the new states as prime, and we'll
again, we'll use mini-max to summarize what the values are in that new state.
>> I like it.
>> And that equation is sometimes referred
to as mini-max Q, because it's like
the Q learning update but just with the mini-max operator instead of a max.
>> That makes sense.